billy talk about pink floyd for a second
because i asked you to do a cover today
and
why is pink floyd and why is this song
important to you
i think this is the first song that ever
really landed with me personally
if it makes any sense like i felt like
this person is
if i could write a song this is the song
i wish i'd write and the great irony is
that when i
inducted pink floyd and rock and roll
hall of fame this is actually the song i
played with him on stage
which is even more of a crazy
mind-blowing thing so but this was the
first song i was like wow this person is
singing for me
not singing about somebody like me this
person's singing for me so this song's
always
really connected with me in a personal
way wow love to hear it
love to hear your take on it
[Music]
[Applause]
sound
[Music]
blue skies from pain
can you tell
[Music]
do you think you can tell
did they give you the train
[Applause]
[Music]
change did you exchange
[Applause]
[Music]
year
wish you were here
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful that's one of those songs you
said when your grandmother was uh dying
that you listened to over and over again
somehow got you through it but
yeah yeah that's why when people tell me
when people tell me that about my songs
i take it very seriously because i
really know what that feels like
how one song can really like keep you
from jumping off a roof
so it's always and it sounds like a
weird thing to say it's probably the
greatest compliment you can get because
you think like wow
it didn't just do something like get
somebody down the road like it actually
kept them
like from you know on the side of
sanity or something